(solemn music)
- [Interviewer] In an age of call outs,
culture wars and perfect facades,
people can be afraid to
express how they really feel.
So we brought together seven strangers,
protected their identities,
and asked them all seven
burning audience questions.
What will be revealed
when we take the mask off?
If your answer is, yes,
you'll turn your light on.
(drum beats)
(beep) The police.
(counter beeps)
- [William] I know that there
are quote unquote "good cops"
but if you are working in the entire force
with individuals who are
essentially mostly racist
and where police come
from, the history of it,
with being the sheriffs of slaves
and tracking down slaves using dogs
or whatever they're using,
it's just, wearing that badge,
you're never really here for us,
and we never feel safe for
that reason so (beep) them.
(someone chuckles)
- [Terrence] The only reason
why I can't fully say that,
like he just said there
are some good out there,
and personally having a cousin
who is a police officer,
but everything else behind that
and all of the other people who introduce,
who bring the racist and pretty
much (beep) mentality to it,
yeah no, it's (beep) them for sure.
- [Interviewer] All
right, we're gonna have
everyone join the conversation.
- [Kennedy] I don't really feel
anything towards this statement
because I haven't had any
encounters with police, like ever.
- [Maurice] Why do you have
to have a personal experience?
Why can't you just look at the
damage that's has been done-
- [Kennedy] It's different
'cause I feel like
I feel the weight of my
ancestors in certain situations,
in other areas of my life
than I do with the police.
- [William] Okay, this is
not me taking away from
the Black community in general,
'cause police are always targeting us,
but I find it interesting
that only the Black men
had agreed with that.
- [Female] Yeah.
- [Alexus] I'm on the fence with it
because I know that there
are Black cops out there
that are truly trying
to protect and serve,
and I really don't know what I would do
if we completely destroyed
the police system.
I would be scared because it's like, okay,
well I don't believe that is the solution,
but yes, Black men have that
main encounter with the police.
And sometimes it's
annoying because it's like,
okay is this the only
cause that y'all care about
is police brutality?
But yeah, I just, it's halfway with me.
- [Terrence] I think feelings do become
more intense though once
you have an experience.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Obviously.
- No, definitely.
- And so, seeing situations
where my dad got pulled over,
got questioned, got
harassed for no reason,
then to experience my
situation down in Texas.
I mean, I had bought
guns for the first time,
registered them, followed
everything to the T,
and then still get pressed
up against the side of my car
like I did something wrong
when I did it the exact way
that y'all said I had to do it.
That experience right there,
my dad's situation started it,
and then my situation
is what finalized it.
(drum beats)
- [Interviewer] Are
Asians racist towards you?
(counter beeps)
- [William] I have a neighbor
who is very privileged.
She's married to a white man, she's Asian,
and I feel like that comes
a lot nowadays in America.
I feel like Asian women are trying
to be the white woman of America,
and they're not realizing
that they're also
in marginalized
communities, just as we are.
- [Alexus] Especially Asians that are born
into American culture.
It seems like they're
just pretty much white,
and they don't have any
empathy for other minorities.
- [Maurice] I have had
negative interactions
with Asian people or other
people because I'm Black
and because colorism is a thing
but I've also had positive interactions.
So, I feel like, yeah,
Asian is just a very generalized term.
- [Jasmin] I know it happens of course,
but me personally I have
not experienced racism
from the Asian community.
I do totally agree with
the idea of colorism
because it does seem
like the darker you are,
the quote "uglier you
are" in any ethnicity,
which does suck.
- [Terrence] I think the
American influence is big
and that's on anybody that comes,
no matter where you come
from, what background.
When you get to America, you
spend a couple years here,
you start to see how things are done,
whether they're right or wrong,
you see how things are done,
how Black people are treated,
how white people are treated.
So a little bit after I left the military,
I spent a couple years in Malaysia,
Singapore, Indonesia and South Korea.
These places were places
where I was accepted
more so than back home.
It was shocking to me to not
be followed around in stores
in South Korea.
It was shocking to me to not be treated
or even looked at the same way I would be
walking down the street
in certain places here.
(drum beats)
- [Interviewer] I have
dated outside my race.
(counter beeps)
- [Kayla] In my past
dating history I feel like
I tasted the rainbow pretty much.
(panelists laugh)
I've dated East Asian man,
I've dated Hispanic men.
It's different.
You're never gonna find
somebody outside of your race
that's gonna a hundred
percent understand you,
understand your struggle,
understand your family,
why you do things the way that you do.
When I'm dating them I know
it's gonna be different,
and I feel that's why I'm entertaining
the fact of even doing that.
- [Maurice] I don't think that
I would necessarily date a white person.
I just feel like there's a disconnect,
but as long as they're willing to
have those conversations with me
and understand my blackness,
I wanna have those
conversations with them,
and I don't mind what their race is.
- [Terrence] I think for me,
it's just all about my
comfort level with you
and how much I can relate.
And like he said, I think a white woman
would be at the bottom of the totem pole
just because we don't have
that much to connect on,
but I'm not opposed to it.
I would just kind of
rather work with something
that I know there's a lot
of compatibility there.
- [Kennedy] I'm not opposed
to dating outside my race,
but in terms of marriage,
I would love to marry a Black man, yeah.
- [William] Think about our ancestors.
They're probably turning in their grave.
They're like, what are you doing?
We've done so much and you
wanna be with this white person
or this non-Black person?
- [Alexus] I've never
dated outside of my race,
but maybe I should
because a lot of Black men
tend to go to non-Black women.
- [Male] 'Cause they can control them.
- [Alexus] Yes, and because-
- [Female] 'Cause they're easier.
- [Alexus] And because they
have European features,
softer hair, they like the
Kim Kardashian-looking woman.
You know, you want the
Black woman aesthetic
but you need the European features.
So, maybe I should date
outside of my race,
but I personally, like you said,
I wanna build with a Black man.
I wanna have Black children.
That's what I want to do,
but with this generation of Black men,
I don't know if it's possible.
- [William] Me having sex with a white man
is just, it's the master aspect.
It's the buck breaking history,
if you know what buck breaking is.
It's all of that combined.
And then, the idea of most times,
even in heterosexual relationships,
it's usually a fetish for the
individual to be with you.
It's either because you have a nice body
or your skin is so dark and lovely
or because you have, you know,
that tool that they want,
if y'all know what I'm talking about.
(panelists laugh)
So yeah, in general, it's always something
on your body that they want.
And if it's genuinely true
love, that can happen,
but for the most part,
I just think interracial
dating is disgusting.
(drum beats)
- [Interviewer] I've felt
oppressed by my own community.
(counter beeps)
- [Alexus] I actually sometimes
feel very uncomfortable
in spaces full of Black people.
If you're not desirable as a Black woman,
if you're not desirable to men
then you tend to get overlooked.
I have to work my ass off
for things that I want.
Black men, CIS hetero
Black men specifically,
they oppress all of us and it sucks
because I wanna be with a Black man
but it's like, I have to try
to appeal to my oppressor.
- [William] I'm gay and I'm also Black.
So, within the Black community,
I feel like, again, when
we go to these protests,
when we go out to these clubs or parties
and I'm in heterosexual spaces,
I feel like, oh, it's yeah
he's Black, but he's gay,
so we can't really mess with him.
He can't really be in our space.
And it's like, how is this
your space that you claimed
over a sexuality and a sexual
preference essentially,
rather than us being the same race?
- [Maurice] Yeah, of course.
Like you were saying, if
you're in the LGBTQ community,
it's intersectionality.
People are more cool
with me if I'm passing
and they see me as a CIS Black guy
versus if they know I'm trans.
- [Kennedy] In terms of my experience,
I feel like maybe Black people
were gate keeping opportunities
or trying to be super stingy
or trying to be the token Black person.
They kind of bully other Black people
to making them be like, you
don't deserve to be in my space.
This is my zone. This is the
area that I'm working in.
And it's like they're trying
to keep other Black people
from being successful.
I feel like I've seen that a lot,
and I feel like that's
happened me before, too.
- [Kayla] When I was living in Mississippi
I was around predominantly Black people.
I didn't feel any different
but now that I'm back here in California
and I'm around other races,
well I can see why this
could be considered colorist
or I can see how in this situation
maybe I'm feeling like I'm not as worthy
as these other people,
but I just couldn't use
the word oppressed really
to describe how my experiences have went.
(drums beat)
- [Interviewer] Have you ever
wished you weren't Black?
(counter beeps)
- [Jasmin] I wanna say, record
straight, I love myself now.
I love being a Black woman,
but for so long because
of also family members
feeding into the whole
idea of you're so pretty
because you're lighter.
For so long as a child,
I associated being Black
as being something that was a bad thing
because I saw how people
that were darker than me were treated.
And I was just like, oh, I
don't wanna be this anymore.
But I mean, with a lot of love
and compassion and hardcore teaching,
I was like being Black is
honestly the best thing ever.
- [William] We lit.
(panelists laugh)
I just feel like we're lit and
I get where that comes from.
That's a part of colorism.
And that happens a lot in our community.
And I just feel like
if we all just accepted
our blackness more,
we would just be great.
- [Maurice] When I was
younger, I moved to a town
that was predominantly white and Hispanic.
I never felt specifically
like, oh I wish I wasn't Black,
but I did look at other people
and say, "I wish I had hair like them.
I wish I looked more like them."
- [Alexus] I love being the race that I am
but having 4C hair
and having darker
knuckles, darker kneecaps,
especially in elementary
school and middle school,
getting through that was really hard.
Now at this age, I'm learning
to accept all parts of me
but I still battle with it every day.
- [Kennedy] There were
times where I maybe wish
that I wasn't Black American,
that maybe I wish I was an
African woman or Brazilian
because I feel like Black Americans,
we kind of were disconnected
from our African roots and our heritage.
And that part kind of hurts
'cause it's like we don't
really have much to call our own
besides Ebonics or A.A.V.E.,
but Black American cultures
ultimately set the tone
for a lot of modern day pop culture, too.
So I'm proud of that part, as well.
(drum beats)
- [Interviewer] I would
raise my kids differently
than my parents raised me.
(counter beeps)
- [William] If you
haven't had an experience
with whether sexual abuse
or some type of violence in your home,
you are lucky in the Black community
because it happens to so many of us.
And I feel like with me,
experiencing that growing up,
I would never beat my child.
I don't want to have to feel
like beating my child is a
source of them respecting me.
I want them to know about mental health
and take their mental
health actually serious
because we don't take it serious
in the Black community at all.
- [Kayla] I love that you mentioned that
specifically about mental health
because it's something
you can't talk about
in our community sometimes.
It's like, well, what's wrong with you?
Are you crazy?
I'm gonna whoop your tail.
You shouldn't be acting this way.
I give you everything.
You have no reason to be depressed.
I don't wanna reciprocate
that unto my children
and I don't want them to feel
like if they're feeling depressed,
if they're feeling overwhelmed
I don't want them to think
they can't come to me
and talk about it.
My parents, they didn't
have that opportunity
to communicate with their parents
because they were raised
in a completely different generation.
So now, I see my mom
was raising me this way
because that's what she's used to
but I'm gonna cut it off with my line.
- [Alexus] Our kids are
probably gonna be like,
yeah I ain't doing that
when I have my kids.
Each generation gets wiser
and they learn something else
or have resources to something else.
I just wanna always highlight
the good things that my parents did.
I've already acknowledged them
and addressed the bad things with them,
but now I can forgive and let it go
and just highlight what they did do right
and kind of mix that with my own.
(drum beats)
- [Interviewer] I can't
be honest about who I am.
(counter beeps)
- [Maurice] Being Black,
if I'm in a white space,
I'm constantly like, how am I coming off?
But a lot of times, for me,
in terms of being trans also,
like, how am I walking?
How am I talking? How am I being received?
Do these people, are they speaking at me
or looking at me like
they're comfortable with me?
And it's just pretty tiring sometimes
when I'm around other people
and I'm constantly checking myself.
- [Kennedy] Since we're in
the age of cancel culture,
it's just really easy.
I feel like even if you wanna be honest,
it's like sometimes you can't
because you have a fear of getting cancer
or fear of people lashing out on you.
And I feel like in
certain senses like that
I can't be completely honest
in terms of my views on certain things
just because of how
people are going to react.
- [William] It takes a lot
for a person to be themselves
and fully own their identity,
no matter who you are or what you are.
So living in that, I've
learned to own that.
I'm always blunt. I'm always me.
What you see is what you get.
If you got a problem, you can leave.
So, (chuckles) yeah.
- [Alexus] It's exhausting
to try to defend yourself
all the time about who you are,
but at the end of the day
I sleep better at night
knowing that I'm just me.
(upbeat music)